[Music]
the UK is facing its biggest terrorism
challenge in more than a decade
but the threat from returning
Isis jihadis is for now at least not as
significant as had been feared the
predominant threat comes from homegrown
extremists who've never even been to the
battlefields of Syria and Iraq the
police and security services have long
feared that with the crumbling of Isis
in the Middle East many British jihadis
would find their way back home
battle-hardened and motivated they pose
a very obvious threat but security
sources have told us they now believe
the number of returning to Hadees will
be significantly less than originally
expected there are a number of factors
at play more than 800 Brits traveled to
Syria and Iraq around half have returned
but many never fought alongside Isis or
left early disillusioned that the
actions of the terror group we've been
told up to 200 British fighters have
been killed in the region the remainder
are either unwilling or too scared to
come back for fear of prosecution what
has happened is Isis have very cleverly
switched tactics they realize that they
can't get the supply of fighters into
Syria in Iraq and indeed they've been
defeated predominantly in Iraq and at
the same times that they need to carry
on trying to spread terror so what we
have seen them do is use more
inspiration use the internet to
radicalize those people and say you know
take action at home and and do whatever
you can to really kill people
the threat from returning to Hadees may
yet materialize authorities we're told
are tracking around a hundred hardcore
individuals ready to pounce should they
try to return to the UK over the last
six months I think there's been a
development which I would characterize
as positive in the sense that the number
are placed in the several hundreds of
those UK citizens who was thought wood
or mic returned from so-called Islamic
state in Iraq and Syria has now dropped
by all estimates but advances in
communications like the use of encrypted
chat sites is allowing those still in
the Middle East to directly encourage
and instigate attacks here I mean their
difficulty with security services is
that they've now got a threat picture
that is so diffuse so scattered out
they've got a methodology of attack
which is so basic as getting knives
using cars they've got group in Islamic
state who's just shouting about
launching attacks instigating people
inspiring people firing the ideology off
in every direction and so it's being
picked up by all sorts of people and in
some cases getting picked up in a very
short period of time people are latching
onto the ideas and reacting to events
and going to do something in this very
basic way
the template for increased terror
activity was set more than a decade ago
with the dismantling of al-qaeda under
intense pressure from coalition strikes
the group urged followers to launch
attacks in London Madrid and other
Western cities the difference now is the
extent to which a more technologically
advanced terror group is in direct
communication with extremists here the
threat they posed were told will not
diminish anytime soon mark white Sky
News